it's difficult to convey even with these
pictures the extent of the damage here
building after building home after home
street after Street destroyed
one resident told us nordagi is no
longer on the map
where people remain under the rubble the
rescue operation goes on
relatives wait day and night
they sleep here under blankets that
offer little protection against the
bitter cold
but as the days go on many tell us that
they have lost hope
at the moment we are expecting four more
people from our family grandfather
grandmother and granddaughter and a
sister-in-law when they bring them out
we will bury them in our land
we've seen four bodies pulled out of
this building so far 28 people remain
but all hope has been lost to find any
survivors here entire families have been
wiped out in one moment and if you drive
further up the road you're going to see
these scenes being replayed again and
again
and yet incredibly two young children
are pulled out alive by a Spanish Rescue
Team just a few blocks away
days after the devastating earthquake
they survived under heavy Concrete in
freezing temperatures
these are seen as miraculous moments
these days
providing a rare moment of joy for
everyone here
as overwhelmingly it is the Dead who are
emerging from their homes
blankets are used to offer them and
their families some dignity
we are asked not to film as the bodies
are carried past us in black bags
there will likely be many more
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera nudagi in
Southeastern turkia